I think any founder who ultimately
plans to sell something to somebody
should be thinking about their
modernization strategy from day one.
The reason is not,
because the early revenue, I think makes
a meaningful difference for your
business from a cash flow perspective.
But because acquiring revenue is the
ultimate form of customer validation.
It's pretty easy as
an entrepreneur to go out and
find somebody to tell you
that you have a cool idea.
The difficult part is getting
them to open their wallet.
So from that perspective,
I see it as a really,
really great tool in
understanding your customer and
understanding that you've found
something that people want.